Caméra tourne. Petit clap.
Euh...les copains
*Clap*
*Rires*
Alors qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette 15ème paire, 15ème, 15ème, 15ème, 15ème ?
Hrm, hrm...
Pense au chiffre 15 !
*Rires*
Alors qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette, oh putain, de cette 15ème paire ?de cette 15ème paire?
-Bah dit 14ème. -Ok.
*Rires*
Alors qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cette, huah !
*rires*
On a un peuple plein de "ressour" on a un
-Ok (-"Ressour")
*rires*
Ouais je suis en caleçon ouais !
Y a un problème?
Est-ce que tu peux aussi le mettre sur un petit cintre ?
Bien sûr, bien sûr, j'peux l'faire
Et ton slip il allait où ?
*Rires*
Voilà : c'est un beau cadeau !
Ouais
Qu'est-ce que t'en penses?
*rires*
L'impro nulle
C'est clair !
Bon, euh, qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cette treizième paire là ?
*Rires*
Vas-y, vas-y !
C'est bon?
Attends.
Allez c'est parti.
Alors qu'est ce que vous
pensez de cette quinzième paire?
*Rires*
Par exemple les, prochains, c'est Charlie et Lulu.
huum Charlie et Lulu...
Par exemple, les prochains c'est Spirou et Fantasio.
Nan nan, nous c'est ... nhhhh
*rires*
Toujours plus compliqué quoi.
Gratte...
gratte...gratte...
Whou!
J'ai démoulé une merde là dedans...
Et allez pas craquer une allumette ça va exploser, hein.
*rires*
Eh c'est beaucoup trop drôle put*in, attends.
Allez on se concentre là...
Descends-le dans la gorge.
*rires*
Attends...
Allez, une dernière.
*avale*
*rires*
Fais-le...
Fais-le descendre dans ma gorge.
*rires*
Vas-y.
Et let's go !
*rires*
T'ain énorme.
Et tu vas faire ça sans protections?!
*rires*
-Calcul...
-Youtube Money?
*rires*
Grave!
-Revenus annuels?
-Youtube Money.
*rires*
Whou put*in j'ai démoulé une merde...
Ouf, allez pas là dedans!
*rires*
J'étais morte de rire
*rires
Excusez-moi, je peux plus me retenir!
Whou! J'ai démoulé une merde
allez pas exploser...
Allez pas craquer une allumette là-dedans, ça va exploser!
L'accent du Sud était très bien, hein!
Le Nord de la France,
c'est l'un des Musées naturels
les plus célèb...*rires*
Qui a inspiré Emile Zola...
Emile Zola dans l'un des...prhh
Emile...Emile et Image.
*rires*
*Dans l'un des lheivre*
Whou! J'ai démoulé une merde là-dedans!
Who, putain, j'ai lâché une...Attends.
C'était trop drôle, ça!
Et allez pas craquer une allumette, ça va exploser, hein!
Met un peu de carotte! Met de la carotte. Vas-y.
[rires]
A mon avis pour la sécurité, faudrait nettoyer le pare-brise.
Et qu'est-ce t'y connais, toi?
[rires]
Tiens, met-les moi.
Eh, euh, c'est très mal mis là.
Il est pas fifou cet hôtel, hein.
Ouais, il...euh...hein?
-Oh ben, euh, Merlin nous a suivis jusqu'à l'hôtel!
- Oh ben alors ça!
Si c'est pas de la fidélité!
Ah oui les oreillers ils sont hypers durs.
[hors champ: C'est très drôle!]
C'est pour ma file, elle est vraiment toute petite.
Elle fait ma taille à peu près?
Qui a inspiré Emile Zola dans l'un des célèbres...P****n, mais...!
brouhaha incompréhensible
qui  a  inspiré  emile zola  dans l'un  des  plus
[rires]
qui  a  inspiré  emile  zola dans  les  plus  grand  livre
brouhaha
je  suis  quand  même  une  bête  de  flûte
mange  le  cher
attention  mâche    bien  sinon  tu  vas mal  digérais
abonne  toi  si  ta  aimais  la  video  gadou133